Ukraine's Capital Kiev is under attack
as Russia pushes forward in the second
day of its invasion residents of Kiev
heard Air Raid Sirens this morning and
explosions were heard in the hours
before Dawn an apartment building was
partially destroyed by Apparent shell
fragments the Ukrainian Army says it is
now fighting Russian forces outside the
capital
we're waiting for confirmation of that
sirens and explosions have also been
heard in other cities across Ukraine
this is the situation right now in the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev these are live
pictures as you can see it seems fairly
calm at maidan square one of the main
landmarks in the heart of the city but
we have noted in our rolling coverage
that many people have been hiding in
shelters and underground stations after
a second night of explosions and the
early hours of the morning in the
capital as well our correspondent we
were speaking to earlier Matthias
Bollinger also having to uh evacuate his
position having said that shelling had
begun in the capital
the Ukrainian government says at least
137 people have been killed and hundreds
wounded across the country since
Russia's Invasion began early on
Thursday Russia is continuing its air
sea and land assault taking territory
including the former Chernobyl nuclear
power plant
Ukrainian President Vladimir solenski
says the fate of Europe is being decided
in his country
Ukrainian soldiers on the outskirts of
the eastern city of khakive inspecting
just some of the Carnage from day one of
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
then after dusk the destruction
continued
kahit civilians took refuge in subway
stations looking for whatever safety
they could find
also in the Ukraine Capital Kiev people
headed for the underground fearful
Russia could launch airstrikes
I'm here because I think it's one of the
only places right now where you can hide
in Kiev all the other places are
terrifying
foreign at a Strategic Air Base just 20
kilometers away from the capital reports
of Russian forces and control however
Ukraine says it prevented a complete
takeover of the facility
Ukrainian troops have set up roadblocks
throughout the city's government quarter
late on Thursday night Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski said he was
aware of the danger but that he was
remaining in the capital
according to our information the enemy
has listed me as Target number one and
my family as Target number two
they want to destroy the country
politically terminating the head of
state
satellite images also show the
destruction Russia is raining down on
Ukraine here the damage to airfields and
the east of the country
and Russia is proving it's not only
interested in military facilities
Ukrainian officials confirmed they've
lost control of the decommissioned
Chernobyl nuclear power plant
the scene of the world's worst nuclear
disaster is now in Russian hands
DW correspondent joins me on the line
from outside Kiev funny what is the
situation now in the capital I believe
you've moved yourself out just tell us
what you've been through overnight since
we last spoke
well to say that the situation is tense
will be quite an understatement actually
at this point it is a terrifying given
what we actually went through last night
we had to stick shelter ourselves to the
sirens going off and in fact just like
yesterday should be after 4am the first
explosions were hurt
the first explosions they heard can you
hear me yes I can I can I can hear you
loud and clear
hello
funny I can hear you fine if if uh if
you can hear me keep talking tell us
tell us more about the night and what
you went through yeah we're gonna thank
you so much for uh there was an acoustic
problem here so it was a quiet
terrifying situation tonight as we had
to shout the seek shelter ourselves uh
we could only uh keep up with the
reporting from inside there was a
perfume place which still is in place of
course from 10 pm until 7 A.M and we
just had to honk her down just like
everyone else as you have seen in that
report people aware are trying to speak
for shelter in the subway in the Metro
station and in fact as for this moment
we try to be Keith which is a chance for
itself just in front of me traffic is
building up it's not just us who is
trying to leave but tens of thousands of
people are with us already up here and
they're around 100 000 ukrainians have
exited to try to exit the roads that are
still open towards the western part of
Ukraine but let me tell you there's so
many rumors that at this point that some
people really wonder is it the right
time to leave or is it better to stay
put I'm not I'm not invested in rumors
but what I can tell you for sure that
given the escalation of the conflict
also the shelling that he experienced
early this morning there is an
indication that actually a bigger clash
and really a terrifying a situation
that's going to play out Ukrainian and
Russian forces as the battle is going to
be playing out here at the capital city
of Ukraine already as we have seen there
was a back and forth in terms of who is
going to control that critical military
airport about 60 kilometers
side of keys currency according to
Ukrainian information in Ukraine it
still holds the position which in Star
is a success for Ukraine because after
all we of course know that Russia is
quite Superior in terms of military
personnel military care and so to them
actually it is what I should say is
being expressed as a very successful
situation but the Ukrainian government I
mean of course very important to
motivate people who are extreme put here
who want to defend their country and not
to give up their sovereignty to a
Russian forces what about the Ukrainian
president he is said to still be in the
country how dangerous is the situation
for him right now
Ukrainian president is
saying he knows that he's the number one
enemy for Russia right now he's and the
number two enemy is his family but he
says he's going to stay and everything
what we know about what his actions or
policies in the next hours are going to
be we can read on Twitter in fact he
took to Twitter again to say that he
wants to actually call on a NATO Airline
such as to help with a more military uh
defensive assistance but also in fact he
calls on his counterpart in Poland Mr
Duda to some more help and mediate here
that there is a negotiation possible
still with Vladimir Putin to basically
bring back coaching to negotiation table
this is what zelensky actually just
announced a short while ago which
clearly tells you that Mr zelenski is
still somehow trying to uh probably uh
really prevent uh that this is going to
further escalate into unfortunately more
Bloodshed as we have already seen there
were already schools of people injured
and killed in this new level of
escalation which at this point is a flat
out whose scale Invasion by Russia and
aggression that is is that of uh equal
to to rule even though Russia never
declared a war they declared a military
operation but what is happening is with
an invasion from all sides from the from
the north rather from the northern part
uh of Ukraine from the south from the
East
it is a uh really terrible situation
right now for the people in Ukraine who
cannot decide still though is it safe
enough for them to leave but also for
very practical reasons because they do
not have gasoline they do not have the
logistics to leave funny what are the
main ways out right now
the way out or the main way that
everyone is speaking right now is still
the roots uh towards live which is the
uh let's say the the biggest town
towards uh the western part of Ukraine
or on the Western border of Ukraine
neighboring
neighboring Poland that is the route
that everyone is seeking at this point
but of course this can also change by
the by the hour given that the the
Russian forces are trying to uh
apparently limit of people from from
leaving where they are they want to
insert the kids as a result it's going
to be very difficult to make a decision
which direction to take
for us reporting stay safe she was in
Kiev yesterday but as you heard there
there's been shelling and they've now
moved their position uh further to the
west of the country we'll be in touch
later in the day thank you very much
Fanny
thank you
well Dima kochenko is in manitsky in the
west of the country he works for the DW
Academy which promotes media freedom and
he moved his family out from Kiev just
yesterday tell us about your day and
what you've been experiencing
uh hi well it was quite uh complicated
yesterday uh we woke up at 5 30 a.m
because we heard the explosions and it's
very hard to confuse this sound with
something else and we understood
straight away that the word has started
so we um like without any hesitation we
took our kids and I have two and we got
into the car and started to get out of
Kiev because when the standard cave is
would be the main goal right of Russian
aggression and
it took us about 10 hours to take the
kids to my hometown which is in the
western Ukraine well usually it's about
three hours it was a massive traffic
jams and you could see uh buildings on
the horizons burning and smoke was going
out for them it was pretty scary and
then hour by hour the news started to
come out that Russians are invading
Ukraine through several borders it was
very scary I would say Tina what was
going through your head when you made
that 10 hour Journey with two kids in
the car
um
first of all you don't believe that it's
happening you cannot believe and even
when you see tanks Ukrainian tanks go in
like on the other side of the road
because I was going to the west and they
were in the East you just cannot believe
that it's true it is it looks like
you're in some kind of film but then
when you see the news and you hear the
radio you start believing it and
like it's like all all you have all you
have in your head is basically fear and
uh you just don't believe that it's true
you see this situation progressing I
mean for you you're you're basically it
sounds like you're on the Run
um what are you going to do with your
family and and what are your
expectations
well yeah it just uh to some extent we
are on the run because but the first
goal was to get out of the danger zone
and which we did yesterday of course no
one slept yesterday and I have my
friends come and also uh who who left
later it took them about 12 to 15 hours
because of the traffic and for the main
task of the yesterday was to make sure
that we are safe and that our friends
are safe and today I think it's a
waiting day we need to understand what
will happen next to my understanding
Kiev will be the main goal and we
already hear the news and my friends who
stayed say that you can hear the
shooting in the bombing and there are
fights in cave right now
so we will understand the status by the
end of the day and then we'll decide I
think that probably we need to secure my
family and my kids either somewhere here
in Ukraine or make sure that they're
safe abroad I am not allowed to go
abroad because mobilization was
announced this night and every man 18 to
60 can be drafted and he cannot be
allowed to leave Ukraine so and then
we'll probably
wait for the development of situations
and if we have to fight then we will
fight
how prepared would you say you are to
fight for your country
I'm absolutely not
I mean uh Frankly Speaking I've never
had a gun in my hand in my life I never
showed a firearm so I am not prepared at
all
and your family what what does it think
about
uh what you're going to do
yesterday night my daughter who is six
years old she asked me if I'm going to
war
and I said if I have to I will and of
course she asked me not to do that
but
you see like when your country is
invaded who it's not us
we'll do it
okay we'll have to leave at their DW
employee Dima kilchenko in Western
Ukraine thank you very much for talking
to us
thank you
I'm recapping the latest developments on
Russia's war on Ukraine Ukraine's
Capital Kiev has come under renewed
attack as Russia ramps up its Invasion
now in its second day air raid sirens
have sounded in Kiev and other cities
this morning and blasts were heard in
the hours before Dawn
an apartment building was partially
destroyed Ukrainian Army says it is now
fighting Russian forces outside the
capital clashes have been reported in
the city's North
the Ukraine government says dozens have
died since the invasion began and
hundreds more have been injured
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
addressed his Nation this morning he
told ukrainians that they were also
targets of Russia's attacks
it's the second morning of a full-scale
war at 4am the Russian forces continued
making rocket strikes on the Ukrainian
territories they say civilian objects
are not the target it's a lie the
reality is they make no discrimination
wherever they act just like yesterday
both military and civilians are under
Russian attack the purpose of this
attack is to pressure us to put pressure
on you citizens of Ukraine on our whole
society
and we can now go to our Russian Affairs
analyst Constantine Eggert on the line
from Vilnius Lithuania
um Constantine could you first of all
just comment on what we were hearing
from one of our colleagues there in the
west of the country about his prospects
he's been called up to fight his family
is looking for safety and is on the move
through the western part of the country
what's going to happen with all of these
refugees
it is a very important question then
because uh there may be potentially
millions of these people trying to
escape War uh via the border of the
European Union uh Poland and Slovakia uh
and actually Hungary too so I think that
there's going to be a big Exodus of
people from Ukraine and the European
Union should be prepared for that
as for our colleague who may be drafted
and never expected to be drafted of
course well as far as I understand such
people are given basic military training
and of course it is a very high risk
thing to send unprepared people
um to the front but it seems that this
is what is happening and will be
happening uh with uh the with Ukrainian
men essentially who are being called out
and this is a logical tragic but logical
continuation of uh what actually happens
in such circumstance I mean having a gun
shoved in your hands for the first time
um where does that put ukrainian's Army
uh when it comes to fighting off the
Russians
well the first and foremost of all uh as
far as there is a core of professional
Army in Ukraine
and
quite a lot of volunteers who thought uh
in the East
uh all these eight years so there are
much more many prepared people who can
fight as far as I understand also and
this seems to me quite logical uh lots
of people were prepared in a
paramilitary way and there will be
people who know how to handle guns I
don't know hunters for example people
that exercise in Rifle clubs uh who will
be prepared to fight I think that this
is actually Russia's biggest challenge
you can occupy Ikea I think that we we
see it's possible but what we're going
to do next uh you can't essentially run
a 44 million country with the hugest
biggest territory in Europe uh with an
occupation force or even actually I
think 150 to 200 000. that's impossible
and it's a very diverse country it's a
country that's prepared to resist I
think that this is a very very hard
military Endeavor for Vladimir Putin and
Frankly Speaking I think that this day
that just passed first day of War a real
war
um is already a PR disaster
we don't see you know uh joyous crowds
Flags bread and salt
seren Columns of surrendered uh
Ukrainian soldiers this is what is
expected I mean forgive me for something
cynical that is what is expected from
such kind of lightning war with a big
propaganda twist we see nothing of that
Constantine there's been much talk with
the Ukrainian Army being vastly inferior
to Russia's but we are getting reports
of some small victories if you will by
the Ukrainian Army including missiles
striking a military Airfield in rostov
in southern Russia how significant is
that though
it is very significant I think to me I
mean my Army experience is limited to
three years as an officer in the
national service after the university
but my understanding of that is that
this is part of a very very significant
strategy of taking the fight to the
Russian territory of course the Army is
much smaller and uh of course it's much
more limited but it is a signal to the
Kremlin we can make things very
unpleasant for you for example you heard
reports about the possibility of the
Russian special forces saboteurs being
already in care well it's a 2 000
kilometers porous border between the two
countries you can infiltrate Ukrainian
saboteurs into Russian cities to strike
let us say Russian military sites I mean
I I wouldn't be surprised if this
happens this is something that not only
the Kremlin but I think also and that's
probably more important the Russian
population does not expect so in a sense
it is a very serious part of this hit
maybe not very significant militarily
the hit on the Russian Air Base uh is a
very potent psychological uh uh uh
strike in a in a cycle War that's being
waged now by the two side Constantine
thank you very much for the analysis
thank you